[موسيقى]
حياكم الله سياره جديده ونجم جديد السياره
اليوم ما راح احكي لكم عنها ولا كلمه الان
اديكم انتم تكتشفونها من شكلها مدركسون من
الكراسي اكيد بتكتشفون
[موسيقى]
كده
ابو محمد شلونك
مفتوح طيب تصوير كان الجناب الماما مع
الفنانه الكبيره الهام الفضاله حاكني ابو
محمد على المسرحيه الجديده الاسم سياسي
موضوعا اجتماعي جدا هي ايضا معها مثل
النفسيه يعني يمكن تطرقه لها عن لندن كثير
بس هذي العائله يعني كل عوائل راحت لندن
تغير جو
اللي تشوفها بلندر تصير معك عرفت صارت في
المسرحيه
جميله تبقى محمد
اصدقائي
محمد ما في احلى منه
في البروفات
اللي مكتوب كويس
من عندك الدكتور حقك الخروج على الناس
هذه بنحكي عنها بعدين بعدين
الناس انا دائما حتى في الرساله نص يكتب
اكثر من مره فانت اليوم ممثل لما يجي على
ارض الواقفه واشتغلت قلت لا لقيت شيء
مختلف اي لا خنزير هنا احلى الزاويه
عشان البرنامج ههه
ههه زين يعني يقولوا لي مسرحياتك تطول
اكثر من ههه
اول اكثر من ثلاث ساعات
ما عاد اقعد اكثر من ثلاث ساعات
هذه
ساعتين وربع ساعتين ويعني هذا حدها ممتاز
ابو محمد
همم يا ولد ولد ههه
ابو محمد صار في واحد في المسرح همم يعني
في المدرج في المدرج يعني وراء بالاخير كل
الممثل النجم ما يقول يعني كما يشيلها مع
الجمهور فهمتني هذا تبعكم
ههه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
يعني
يجي فنان مو فنان
يسوي حفله بالكويت ممكن تقولوا له ستوب
الله
الامه الحبوبه الغاليه حتى لو تزعل عرفت
زعله الام والاخت العوده عرفت اللي سعاد
ميزان طيب عبد الرحمن العقل وانا مسوي
للحين هذه المساله
طب صديقك المكرر لا ابو خالد غزاوي
حسن حسن
يعني انا اقول لكم
البنت اللي يبي لها شوي هاه
المثل يقول لمن لا يعني وجد ما لا يرضيه
عرفت
العروس الجميله
السيارات
470 حصان
وسياره سوي مخالفات
مش مش يعني لك
بربك فوق المعافي
القصف القمر
الكلام لا هو حلو ان الدوره
الحياه حياتي اوروبا
[ضحك]
اسمع اسمع مثلا
حبيبي
همم
[موسيقى]